today's episode is sponsored by blinkist
the app that lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
totally free
and get 25 off a subscription when you
go to blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
below this video
you know for all of the fear-mongering
about democrats
really being socialists obama was a
marxist
bernie is a communist all of this stuff
you've been seeing it for years
is it possible that donald trump is the
most
socialist president that we've ever had
or at least
in decades you know we did a story a
year or two ago
about is donald trump the first atheist
president we talked about other
non-religious presidents or
presidents believed to be non-religious
and
we talked about the reality that donald
trump appears to be lying about being
religious
just to try to placate evangelical
voters it doesn't make trump a better
president not to be religious but he
just might not be
religious despite his claims that he
loves the bible and all of this stuff
well what about trump as a socialist
president now to be clear
trump is not a socialist but we are
talking here about
the the sort of haphazard definition of
socialism and communism
that the right likes to wrongly ascribe
to the ideas of the left
but there is a long list of the
socialization of some elements of the
economy by donald trump
that could arguably make trump the
closest thing we've had
to the definition of a socialist
president that his
supporters tend to ascribe to socialism
now
you know to be clear there's socialism
and then there's sort of like social
democracy that is sometimes called
socialism
i understand that but let's consider
this and use the spectrum because that's
really what it is
in terms of government stimulus which
the right
loves to call socialism the first
coronavirus relief package was 2.2
trillion in the cares act
trillions coming in additional forms
trillions pumped into the market by the
fed
this is way way way bigger than the
obama stimulus which they
called socialist remember obama was a
socialist for an 800 billion dollar
stimulus bill
and for mandating you buy private health
insurance
from for-profit companies bush's bank
bailout
was about 400 billion this is like 8
trillion in
total trump used the defense production
act
to force general motors to make
ventilators after initial talks broke
down over costs
this is heavy government involvement in
directing the activities
of private industry something that the
right loves to call
socialism in soviet russia the
government tells you
what kind of bread to make trump
threaten to condition the sale of
tick-tock to microsoft
on the u.s receiving a very big
portion of the sale price and said that
nobody else thinks about deals this way
other than him
straight up saying government will take
a cut
of a private business deal because why
because trump wants a cut
if barack obama had ever suggested
anything like this fox news would have
gone bananas for 10 days
donald trump has massively expanded
direct farm aid from 11 billion in 2017
to more than 32 billion in 2020 all so
he could
pay off the farmers who were hurt by his
trade war he has
socialized a larger portion of
agriculture
than previous presidents when harley
davidson wanted to move some of its
manufacturing over to europe
trump threatened them with regulating
them and taxing them like never before
this is extraordinarily heavy-handed in
terms of a government crackdown
on a business that the right calls
socialists when a democrat suggests
doing it trump moved to prop up the
local
the uh domestic coal industry
despite the market deciding it's time to
wrap up coal coal doesn't make sense
the government is overriding markets
to decide which industry will succeed or
fail
wow and where is the right on this trump
has also raised the deficit
massively obama left office with about a
500 billion
deficit down from 1.5 trillion remember
that deficit not debt trump doubled
where barack obama left off
before coronavirus and now obviously
with coronavirus
everything is completely out of control
the right loves to say
those socialist democrats raise the
deficit but it's trump who's done
it historically trump when asked about
debt and deficit deflects and talks
about you know we've got to build up the
military and the wall
and that's going to help the overall
economy
which is almost like a modern monetary
theory type argument
which is just do the projects and the
economy will benefit except trump's
doing it with the wrong projects that
would make sense to say
you know improving health care and
education in the short run might
increase the deficit
but we will benefit so much that in the
long run it will actually be
deficit negative or deficit neutral
trump's sort of making that argument
but with the wrong things like building
a wall as an example
now trump supporters will say trump
didn't want to do any socialism
but he had to do it because of
coronavirus for the good of the country
and that's true to us
to a certain degree but it's what he did
nonetheless
a true capitalist would have said let
the businesses fail
if you don't want to fly because of a
virus let the airlines go under that's
not
what donald trump is doing it's also the
experience of fdr by the way i mean
he arguably somewhat reluctantly
came to some of the policies he came to
in order to kind of save capitalism from
itself now
fdr is seen by some as the most
socialist president we've had trump has
arguably done more
presidents have to respond to the events
of their presidency that's for sure you
can't remove coronavirus from it
sort of like imagining lincoln's
presidency without the civil war
or fdr's presidency without recovering
from the great depression
in world war ii trump had to deal with
coronavirus but he chose to do it this
way it could have been done other ways
now of course trump has also done other
things that are not
socialistic right he's deregulated
business so business can pollute more
so cars can be less efficient cut
funding to agencies cut taxes for some
people but
despite all of that by many measures
trump could still be the most
socialistic president
in many of our lifetimes you've got to
go back at least to nixon
who created the epa osha boosted
regulations social security benefits
maybe you'd go back to dwight eisenhower
who passed the interstate highway act
subsidized mortgages and college tuition
had a 91
top marginal tax rate despite lots of
ways to reduce the effective tax rate
what's the reaction from trumpists
absolutely none
they're too busy trying to suppress the
vote to actually care about what it is
that donald trump is doing
weird times we live in my friends
there's a very
interesting new poll from the wall
street journal about this upcoming
election and it's interesting
not because it says biden is ahead by
nine it's we have many polls that say
that and it may be true
if we uh see the margin of error biden
plus nine might really mean
biden plus two that's nothing new here
what's interesting about this new poll
is that it breaks down trump versus
biden
along a number of different voting
groups and when you look at it when you
slice and dice the electorate you see
that donald trump is winning among
men barely 47 43. that's interesting
because republicans tend to win among
men by more than four points we'll talk
about that more
on friday trump is winning among white
voters
barely 49 to 47 and donald trump is
winning among people with high school
or less education by a huge margin
nearly 20 points trump is up 54-36
among what are colloquially called the
uneducated now
every other group every single other
group donald trump
is losing some examples include black
voters
bidens up 88 to 80 brutal people with
postgraduate degrees biden is up 65 to
28
people who are college graduates biden
is up 61 31
among women and among hispanic voters
biden has 57
support and importantly among
independents biden is up 24
49 to 25. now when you see this
you have to consider whether some of
these things are casual
are causal or correlated so for example
the more education you have the more
likely you are to vote biden we see that
right high school or less
biden has 36 supports 36 percent support
if you have some college biden has 47
support if you graduated college biden
support goes up to 61
and if you have a postgraduate degree
biden is up even higher to 67.
i believe this is causal i don't think
this is merely correlation
donald trump's campaign has been
objectively one
of lying to voters about things he could
never
possibly do as president and many people
fell for voting for trump that's the
right terminology not everybody but many
people did
more education makes you less likely to
vote for a candidate
like trump and i would argue for
republicans more broadly so in this case
if you want people
to vote for trump you actually benefit
from hurting education
not funding public schools not dealing
with the student lending crisis
so on and so forth so you really have to
look at this stuff and understand the
link to campaign strategy and platforms
there are ideologically based positions
that
politicians will take or parties will go
in the direction of
but there are also self-preservation
directions
are republicans against education
because some of them see it
as anti-religious indoctrination sure
yeah that exists among some right-wing
voters
but a lot of right-wing voters recognize
that the more educated people are the
less likely they are to vote for them
and so that that's really important to
look at
now one last word of caution biden plus
nine
in this poll two and a half months
before the election
is exactly where hillary clinton was
in this poll two and a half months
before
the 2016 election that's all that needs
to be said
trust nothing other than your ability
to vote and to convince others to vote
that's it we are coming up on the david
pakman show's
15th anniversary on august 23rd
on that day we will be sending out to
everybody on our newsletter
a huge membership special the goal being
to have our best month
ever for new memberships this month
because it is our 15th anniversary
to be notified of that special on the
23rd
simply subscribe to my newsletter for
free
at davidpakman.com the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different non-fiction
categories and a subscription is only
about eight bucks
a month and you get the entire library
but you can try it totally free and get
25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
today's new members of the day are jenny
rose and michael pennington
also want to say thanks to today's long
time sustaining member of the day that's
gary urbanowski gary has been a member
for almost five years and is today's
sustainer of the day
join these great people by grabbing a
membership in under a minute
at joinpakman.com and you will get if
you want you don't have to watch you
can't nobody can force you to listen but
you will have available the daily bonus
show
for our members only hey this is sort of
funny donald trump did a press briefing
over the weekend once again at his
bedminster
golf club and much like last weekend
some of his supporters who were guests
at the club were allowed to go to the
briefing and it's another example of
trump generating these sort of
rally-like atmospheres with friendly
crowds
even though he's supposed to be
seriously briefing america and the press
about
that thing called the coronavirus
pandemic which killed 7
000 people in the last six days it's
sort of like a
rally uh atmosphere with his supporters
cheering in the background it's weird
but the crazy thing is that even the
friendly crowd and the cheering
couldn't make trump look sensible and he
instantly fell apart
even in front of a friendly crowd so
let's look at some of the clips trump
started by talking about how cases are
going down
despite testing which continues to
expose that donald trump is
very very confused about how testing
relates to cases
and by the way there were 55 000 cases
the day before trump did this press
briefing
listen to what donald trump had to say
nearly 85 percent of jurisdictions all
across our country
are reporting a very steep decline in
cases
and that's despite the fact that we have
the number one testing program anywhere
in the world
we're up to almost 70 million tests far
beyond any other country
this week cases nationwide have declined
by six percent
so of course trump doesn't get it more
testing reduces cases over the long term
because people know they have it they
know they're contagious they stay home
that ship has sailed he's just not going
to understand that or he's refusing
he's at least pretending not to
understand that so then it starts to get
ugly very quickly
trump here suggests that the numbers on
the virus are so good
that he must win in other words how
could a president
who has such great numbers on the virus
not be re-elected that's where donald
trump's mind is
iran would love to have me defeated if
if i win which i hope to win how can you
not when you see numbers like this both
on the
virus and on the economy i mean we
should win we should all be
uh keep this incredible thing going and
i built it once and i'll build it again
i've already
i think the hardest part is done in
terms of the economy and that's with or
without
additional funds remember that as a
country
we have the eighth most cases per capita
in the world
if you don't include tiny countries
which can throw off the data
the us has the sixth most cases per
capita in the world
in terms of deaths we have the 10th most
deaths per capita in the world
again if you exclude places like san
marino and andorra
because they have tiny populations where
the number where just a few deaths
per capita is very high if you exclude
those we are
eighth worst in the world in terms of
per capita deaths and trump says
how could you not reelect the president
with numbers so good
and at the end there you might have
heard trump start to say
uh we're doing great with or without
stimulus money like trump seems to be
suggesting here that the second stimulus
which is being debated right now
it may not even be necessary things are
just fine
which just shows how disconnected he is
from reality
he's asked about that specifically and
here he says it we can do it or not do
the second stimulus either way is fine
for him i guess he means
listen to me listen to me my people are
doing very good and my people call me
they're in the office they call me they
call me when it's right
nobody knows the deal better than i do
when it's right
i'll meet but right now it's not right
they want a trillion dollars to bail out
badly run states
state they're democrat they're all i
mean they're democrat states
will something happen possibly but i
want to tell you the country is doing
very well right now we can live very
happily with it without it
but i'd like to do it because i want to
give money to the people
i like how trump says we can be happy
with or without another stimulus
record unemployment highest gdp drop
on record last quarter businesses
still not functioning fully schools
closed or going remote increasingly as
the virus spreads
but trump is fine with or without a
second stimulus good to know right i'm
glad he's fine with it either way
trump is then asked about polling which
doesn't look particularly good for him
and trump is just rambling about
there are lots of boaters people with
boats who like
trump and have trump flags on their
boats
rivers and oceans thousands and
thousands of boats
it's called boaters for trump voters for
trump pence
there's signs all over some of the boats
have 10 flags on them they're incredible
they're thousands we did nothing to do
this
this is just generic it just happened
the thing is
that you know the white florida boat
owner demographic
isn't enough to win it for trump he may
have enough to win it that's important
but the boaters in the intercoastal are
not enough to win it for donald trump
and here again trump goes into the stuff
about mail and voting
saying we might not know the results of
the november election
not for days not for weeks not for
months we might not know it for years
we are going to have an election that
takes place
on a beautiful day november third and
usually at the end of the evening they
say
donald trump has won the election donald
trump is your new president
whatever they say you know what you're
not going to know this
possibly if you really did it right for
months or for years
because these ballots are all going to
be lost they're going to be gone
and just take a look at a smaller basis
but it's great tests we're doing tests
i mean these are you could call them
polls you could call them tests
look at what's happening all over the
country where you have
universal mail wait a minute the ballots
are lost
there's fraud there's theft it's
it's happening all over the place now
we're going to do it with this whole
vast big section of the country
it's crazy think about how insanely
hyperbolic that is
all the ballots will be lost and we
won't know who won
for years consider how ridiculous that
is
on what planet would we not know the
election results for years and by the
way
does trump know that if that happens he
stops being president on january 20th
it's not clear that someone has actually
said that to donald trump and of course
realistically
if there are a lot of mail-in ballots
and they have to be
postmarked by election day could take a
few days to get
counted it might take a few days to have
the final results and if it's really
close we might not know who is going to
be president in january
until like november 8th that's not the
worst thing in the world
let's get it right in many countries you
don't know the results
at midnight we think that we should that
doesn't have to be the way it is
then trump is asked about birtherism 2.0
which is about kamala harris is kamala
really eligible to be president
trump has a chance to denounce it but he
does not
campaign will you say now that kamala
harris is eligible
to run and be vice president or
president based on
be worn in oakland california so i have
nothing to do with that i read
something about it and i will say that
he is a
brilliant lawyer that i guess he wrote
an article about it so i know nothing
about it but it's not something that
bothers me
but sir when you do that it creates why
do you say that i just don't know about
it but it's not something that we will
be pursuing
let me put it differently let me be let
me put it differently don't tell me what
i know
let me put it differently let me put it
differently
to me it doesn't bother me at all
i don't know about it i read one quick
article
the lawyer happens to be a brilliant
lawyer as you probably know
he wrote an article saying there could
be a problem it's not something that i'm
going to be pursuing
is she eligible i i just told you
i have not gone into it in great detail
if she's got a problem you would have
thought that she would have been vetted
you would have thought that she would
have been vetted by sleepy joe yeah go
ahead
he's like you know i don't know much
about this but the guy who wrote the
article questioning whether kamala can
be vp
because to bvp you have to be eligible
to be president that guy's brilliant
that guy's credentials are super super
good
and and you'd think joe biden would have
vetted her but you know i can't i don't
know anything about that
birtherism 2.0 is building and
it's arguably going to continue building
if other strategies don't go well
here trump does what i call the sir
routine
the sir routine is
we have a name it's crazy that we have a
name the sir routine is when trump
retells a story of someone saying
something to him that is advantageous to
him
and he'll say you know they came to me
and they said sir
blah blah blah you can almost guarantee
it didn't happen the way trump claims it
happened when he does
the sir routine um i want to say that
i want college football to come back
these are strong healthy
incredible people these are people that
want to play football very badly a great
great talent
quarterback trevor lawrence called me on
two days ago i spoke to him a couple of
times
he said sir i want to just tell you we
want it back we want to play and
he's an incredible quarterback as you
know from an incredible school
clemson and uh he's going to have a very
good future
in the nfl sir they told me they came to
me sir
sir please start college football okay
uh some quick ones here donald trump
still
continues to refer to the 1918 flu
pandemic
as happening in 1917 do you agree with
dr
robert redfield who um earlier this week
said if america doesn't follow
public health guidelines we can be in
store for one of the worst faults we've
ever faced from a public health
perspective
no i mean you can't compare it to uh
1917 that was
incredible that was uh that was the
worst ever by far that was you look at
they lost possibly 100 million people no
i don't agree with that but
weirdly trump says that some people call
his own secretary of defense mark
yesper as opposed to mark esper just
like a
very weird moment with your defense
secretary mark esper do you have
confidence in his leadership there
mark jesper can you call him jesper
oh okay some people call him yesterday
no i get along with him
i get along with him fine he's fine and
then here again
it's that raucous atmosphere that donald
trump loves even if it's supposed to be
a serious press briefing
he actually suggests that he might fire
his entire cabinet
if he gets reelected he then dissembles
into rambling and walks off the stage to
the applause
of his club going mostly mask wearing
sycophants
as far as your cabinet goes do you think
you'll see more turnover in your cap
well i don't know i think for next year
i mean generally speaking a lot of times
i understand when
if we win a president will ask for the
resignation of everybody and then bring
back the people he wants that's happened
before steve
and i could see something like that
happening i think that makes sense no
i have a very good cabinet i mean with
few exceptions i wouldn't say i'm
thrilled with everybody frankly
but uh i have overall i think we have a
very good cabinet
i think this i will say this no
administration
none no administration first three and a
half years
has done anywhere near what we've done
300
we will have at the end of the first
term 300 maybe more
federal judges including court of
appeals two supreme court justices
nobody has done this if take a look at
take a look at what we've done
the biggest tax cuts in history biggest
regulation cuts in history
rebuilt our military uh took care of our
vets we have a 91
approval rating from the vets nobody's
ever had a 91 approval rating before
we i guarded the second amendment they
want to destroy the second amendment
take a look at
kamala they want to destroy the second
amendment
and as you know joe is has no control
over anybody
he has no control over himself okay
thank you very much everybody
thank you
that's considered in 2020 among
trumpists
a coronavirus press briefing from the
president of the united states as if
it's a serious thing
the cheering is just too much i would
love to interview the people there right
after they're done
cheering and trump walks off what made
you cheer what
what exactly were you cheering for what
did you hear from the president that you
liked so much
that made you cheer as he walked off
stage and
i've said before even in friendlier and
friendlier settings
trump is on fox and friends a friendly
setting and it goes
terribly i'll talk about that later
trump is on hannity
it's a it's his friend and even hannity
can't make
trump look good a press briefing at his
own club
with his supporters cheering and he
still looks like he has absolutely no
idea what's going
what's going on there is no setting
friendly enough
that can make donald trump look good at
this point in time
we're going to have more coverage of
this on our instagram page
which is david pakman show on instagram
you can also follow me on instagram at
david.pacman coming up next
so much more very busy day as the
democratic national convention gets
started tonight i will be streaming
starting at
8 45 pm eastern time
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent vote
soon 18.
[Music]
welcome back to the david pakman show so
donald trump is very worried about the
attention that the
uh the dnc the democratic national
convention is going to get
this week and one of the things they're
doing is having
campaign advisors kind of manage
expectations their
trump campaign advisors are floating the
idea that joe biden might get
an eight to ten point bump this week
from the dnc
now that's extremely unlikely but the
idea is
if they say biden could get eight to ten
when biden gets three or four which is
typical from a convention
they can say oh no biden underperformed
nobody
likes him we expected him to get eight
to ten points but he only got three or
four so they're doing that
trump's flying to multiple cities this
week to do rally-like
events which we'll be covering
separately so i won't spend a ton of
time on that
right now and in addition to this donald
trump is also doing a bunch of
interviews he's doing a bunch of press
and he started off the week on fox and
friends again
and it went really badly before we start
with the politics i want to start with
the strangest moment
donald trump's younger brother robert
trump tragically passed away over the
weekend in his
uh early 70s trump of course struggles
to show any emotion or human connection
asked about it he's trump says they
say robert was my best friend which is
really weird language to use
about your supposed best friend and
brother take a look at this bizarre
video
hey listen uh you know a lot of people
have been thinking about you and your
family
over the weekend i knew you were able to
get to the hospital before
your brother robert died here in new
york city
we are so sorry for your loss well i
appreciate it it was not
not a great weekend it's very hard you
knew it was going to happen but still
when it happens it's a very tough thing
he was a great guy he was a tremendous
guy you know
he was my friend i i guess they say best
friend and that's true
and you know losing him
not easy that is really really strange
language i guess
they say he was my best friend and
that's that's i guess that's true
what i think is that the statement that
was put out by the white house quoting
trump saying he was my best friend
trump didn't really write it and trump
didn't really say it
so when trump says they say he was my
best friend he really means
the people who wrote the statement
attributing that quote to me
they said he was my best friend and i
guess he sort of was
and then lastly trump is asked again
about his late brother robert trump
and trump's sort of eulogy was about
trump wasn't robert trump wasn't jealous
of my success
and he thought i was a great president
like it's all about trump if you can
believe that
most loyal people there was no jealousy
you know a lot of times in
families i hate to say it but there's
jealousy and
especially among children and among
children that are competitive children
there's because he was very competitive
there was not an ounce of jealousy he'd
go around talking about
how great this is for the country and
it's so incredible and
and he was my biggest fan people would
tell me all the time i spoke to your
brother and your brother was
was so thrilled and and so thrilled at
what was happening and what was
happening for the country was
he was so angry with china because of
what happened where
the plague came in and they shouldn't
have allowed it to happen they could
have stopped it he was so upset by that
it was he couldn't more than people
would be upset a lot of people have
already forgotten
and you can't forget but he was a
fantastic guy
well we're very sorry for your loss and
um well thanks
asked about his brother who died two
days earlier
trump says he was loyal to me he wasn't
jealous of all of my great success
he was mad at china because of the
plague and he thought i was doing a
great job
this is not a person with normal emotion
or with normal
emotional connections to others so
that's out of the way
let's now get into the political stuff
trump again just insisting everything's
fine with the virus
and says without his border wall which
mexico was going
to pay for but didn't uh and which he
was going to build across the entire u.s
mexico border
but didn't he says without that border
wall
things would be much worse which is
ridiculous take a look
can i ask you something about new york
then you shouldn't let it be in office
because we would have
right now the plague coming in like you
know those 280 miles i built have
stopped
like hundreds of thousands of people
mexico is
heavy heavy covered territory they're
highly
infected i built the wall and that wall
to stop people from coming in
if she said that and i know sleepy joe
said it he said
uh we should stop the wall and i might
even tear down the way he wants to tear
down a wall that's
the best border wall ever built in terms
of the success of it so you really hear
that
manic energy from trump shot out of a
cannon as i say
and to add some facts to this trump says
if it weren't for his 280 miles of wall
which is like nothing by the way we
would have hundreds of thousands of
additional cases coming in from mexico
the numbers just don't bear this out
number one in total cases mexico
has 10 percent of the cases that we do
now mexico has fewer people that's true
so per capita the u.s is eighth in cases
and mexico is 57th that's per capita
now that can depend on testing well in
the u.s
we are 10th in deaths per capita mexico
is 13th in deaths per capita so it's a
complete
fantasy world fox and friends allows it
completely uncritically then trump
starts to insist
that the world is calling him because
he's so good at dealing with turkish
president erdogan nobody knows how to
deal with erdogan other than trump
trump tuning his own horn here take a
look hold me up they need help with
turkey
the heads of countries last week they
called me up could you call her to one i
said
why he's you're the only one that he'll
listen to he doesn't listen to us you're
the only one i said
is that because of the united states he
says no that's because of you
that's because of your personality
you're the only one that he
will listen to what about you know what
i don't like saying this publicly but it
happens to be true
i get along with him and he listens and
is this maybe the most narcissistic
thing that we've heard donald trump say
then then trump compares the taliban
to the hosts of fox and friends
interviewing him in this interview this
is weird
reconstituting in afghanistan though and
you couldn't if you look at her issues
you couldn't be more difficult i'll take
them out brian if they're reconstituting
i'll take them out
but we had we had at one point a hundred
more than a hundred thousand soldiers
that's ridiculous
and we're ready to do whatever we have
to do we're dealing with the taliban
i said look let me tell you something
and i've dealt with them directly
these are tough people they're like you
people maybe not that tough
but you know what these are tough people
i said look if you play games
we're going to come and we're gonna hit
you a little harder than any country in
the history of the world has ever been
hit
i guess maybe for trump this counts as
adopting a sense of humor i i don't even
know what's going on
uh trump continues to be unable to
pronounce kamala harris's name correctly
now that may not change
while he continues to allude to the joe
biden dementia stuff he still can't say
kamala's name
maybe people are going to feel sorry for
him and maybe he wouldn't but our
country is too important for that
you're dealing with people that are very
sharp you're dealing with world-class
chess players in the leaders of these
countries i know them all
we do very well with all of them erdogan
of turkey
uh all of them you can't have a guy
that's shot you can't have a guy
that doesn't know where he is you can't
have a guy that's afraid to leave his
basement because he can't speak any
longer
and by the way in his best day he wasn't
good you know that
he was not the guy but but we're not
talking about a bad time
and you can't do that you can't feel
sorry for him and vote for him and
because if that means then the kamala
harrises are going to take over she's a
disaster
look at her positions on everything
kamala of course is a fictional drug in
the series battlestar galactica
joe biden's running mate is kamala
kamala harris
then trump is asked about people
claiming that he might not leave office
if he loses in november
and what's amazing about this is trump
doesn't deny it
he's asked well what about the people
saying you're not going to leave in
november
he just bashes hillary hillary's not
even the person he's running against
this time around
mr president your reaction well the
first thing i think
of is crooked hillary clinton when
during one of the debates she
asked whether or not i would leave
office would i accept the results of the
election do you remember would you
accept
the result and i gave her a decent
answer and
the problem is she didn't accept it she
went crazy she's still going crazy
i mean she's gotten nuts and so so have
they i mean
they call it trump derangement syndrome
i don't know if that's true or not
but it's certainly close i go by the
election now with that being said i have
to tell you
that if you go with this universal melon
where you send millions of votes in
california
tens of millions of ballots being sent
to everybody and their dogs okay
dogs are getting them okay not exactly
inspiring confidence that donald trump
will leave peacefully again i believe he
will leave
but i believe he will do it if he loses
by claiming it was rigged
possibly catalyzing and coalescing his
supporters to real world violence
out in the streets i think it could get
very very ugly
and we need to be prepared for that as
much as we need to be prepared for the
voter suppression
and everything else that is going on
case in point the post office now says
there are
tens of millions of ballots at risk and
that's what i want to talk about next
so you've heard me say it this is not a
rehearsal
this is this is the emergency the postal
service says
tens of millions of ballots mail-in
ballots absentee ballots
are at risk of not being counted
the united states postal service is
warning that
46 states and washington dc
uh in july they warned tens of millions
of voters
might not have their votes counted
because of the
slow mail processing of absentee ballot
applications and eventual ballots
that in april washington post has the
story
that was the earliest sign from the post
office
that if they do kneecap them in terms of
funding which the trump administration
is trying to do it could affect ballot
delivery now i really need people to
understand this because
donald trump and trumpists are saying
something very different
the problem here is not the volume of
ballots okay
please look at the numbers every um
holiday season you know november
december into new year
the post office regularly handles about
1.3
billion greeting cards around the
country okay
even if every voter voted by mail
we're looking at somewhere between 120
and 130 million people voting
that's only 10 of the normal volume of
greeting cards okay
if if we just let the post office do its
thing it would have no problem handling
mail-in ballots
even if every ballot was
by mail instead of in person but that's
not going to be the case only
some people are planning to vote
absentee or vote by mail
the problem is if you cut hours
if you limit overtime if you close down
post offices
if you shut down mailboxes if you quote
reorganize
the post office the way louis de joy
wants to do
you will then cause a problem for the
post office being able to deliver
and do everything that they have to do
the warning
from the post office applies to 186
million potential voters now
not all of those voters are expected to
vote by mail so that's why in practice
it will probably affect
tens of millions rather than you know
186 million
which is the number of people that could
vote in some of these states
it's in blue states it's in red states
it's in battleground states like
pennsylvania wisconsin michigan
so there's a few suggestions here that
are just common sense
i'm going to have a story tomorrow by
the way my
ma this is oh should i even well i'll
mention it
this is crazy my absentee ballot
application
um took 14 days to go three miles
okay i'm going to talk about that
tomorrow but as far as suggestions
request your ballots as early as you can
return your ballot as early as you can
it likely will be too late for some
people in some states like it seems that
we've reached
a post office kneecapping escape
velocity for lack of a better term
we are unfortunately looking at a
situation where if you want
higher confidence that your vote will be
counted you
might have to vote in person now i want
to be careful here i'm not suggesting
anybody do anything unsafe but i'm
talking about
wearing a mask and all of that stuff
what i am saying is
we're hearing from the post office
itself that they are being sabotaged or
sabotaged
as as william shatner says and this
administration is trying to find a way
for your vote not to count now there is
some intermediate good news and this
made some some uh
waves over the weekend and i do want to
amplify it
in a lot of places if you get your
ballot in the mail
you don't have to send it in through the
mail you can drop it off and
different municipalities have different
places town hall city hall different
municipal offices
figure out the specifics in your
community in other places
if it's 10 days before the election and
you don't have your ballot for example
you might have to vote in person to make
sure your vote is going to be counted
and that's horrifying i
i don't want to pretend that that's not
a possibility but because it is
trump is against funding the post office
his postmaster general has reassigned
23 postal executives and is sort of
circling the wagons and consolidating
power
they are talking about the post office
like it's a business when really it's a
public service
you don't say we can't do it you say
okay what do we have to do to make sure
that they can
do it that's what a normal president
would do this president says let's make
sure that they can't do it
so really keep in mind that this local
drop-off might be a good idea
i checked in boston how does it work in
boston in boston
the election website says if you want to
return your ballot in person you can do
that
anytime city hall is open but you've got
to go to city hall
now doesn't seem ideal that anybody all
of boston needs to go to city hall to
return their ballots
in in person but it is something in new
york city i found that quote
all borough offices are equipped with
ballot marking devices
available for voters up until election
day
look it up in your community remember
they
want to take everything away from
government so making the post office
fail
at something as natural as just
delivering ballots
is part of them building up the case
that we should be replacing the post
office with private industry anyway
and they have the added benefit this
time around
that they might be able to win an
election if they're able to do it
very scary i i want to say this is being
taken as seriously as it should
i don't know if it is oh i'm doing
everything i can to sound the alarm
know the options understand the
timelines figure out where you can drop
off your absentee ballot in person if
you're able if you have transportation
and you're able to do it
very very important stuff because this
could get really ugly really quickly
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about them
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
hey so i have something interesting for
you guys right now because
it is yet more trump flunky gaslighting
on corporate media but it's also
a super important kind of critical
thinking and epistemology
concept and it goes to the question of
mayo brained mark meadows didn't think
he was going to be instructive but
how do we know things we do observation
we sometimes generalize we look to
authorities we apply research methods
the scientific method
it's a very big conversation but when
we're dealing with empirical questions
that you're not testing in a sort of
double-blind uh
format we need to apply some other
concepts which we are going to discuss
shortly and this leads us to donald
trump's chief of staff mark meadows
who went on cnn and talked about the
supposed voter fraud of vote by mail
that trump is going to be pushing to
suppress vote by mail this election and
jake tapper from cnn points out
there's no evidence of widespread voter
fraud when people vote by mail
and mark meadows says well there's no
evidence
that there isn't widespread voter fraud
take a look at this
sending ballots out just just based on a
voter roll
registration any time you move you'll
change your driver's license but if you
don't call up and say
no out of the way voter fraud though
there's no there's no evidence that
there's not either that's the definition
of fraud jake when we look at that what
we have seen
are a number of male 1 so this is really
instructive
like not not only does mark meadow's
skull seem to be filled with mayonnaise
here or vegan a's if that's your
preference
this leads us to occam's razor occam's
razor is a concept
which we often interpret or simplify as
if you have competing explanations for
something
we should prefer the simpler explanation
in the sense that it requires the fewest
assumptions
and fewest secondary explanations of
either
unknown or invisible phenomena so i'll
give you some examples
if i say that car seems to be running i
hear it running and the tachometer says
a thousand rpm
i am i believe the car has gasoline in
it
assuming it's not an electric car right
you could come out and say you don't
know that david
the car could be out of gas but you're
hearing a speaker
pumping out noise that sounds like an
engine that's running
and the tachometer might have been
manipulated to show a thousand even when
the car isn't really on
okay i mean i guess that's possible but
it's implausible and the first
explanation which is
when you see a car you hear the noise of
the car running
and the tachometer shows a thousand the
car probably has gas
it requires fewer assumptions and the
person suggesting the wacky hypothesis
should have to provide evidence that
they are right you could say
david you don't have proof that my
theory is false
but intuitively we know that that's the
person that should be proving to
us that we should consider their
hypothesis
another example if i say look it's an
empty room
you could say there could be an
invisible tiger in here
and i'd say well if there was an
invisible tiger in here we would still
hear the tiger
the tiger might smell we might see the
tiger moving around dust as it walks
around and you could say no no
the tiger is invisible but it's also
odorless
and weightless and silent it doesn't
make any noise
and you don't have proof that that's not
going on i think you get the idea these
are indefeasible arguments you can't
defeat them
because they will always say well you
haven't proved otherwise definitively
jake tapper of course should have said
you're asserting some
something for which there is no evidence
so the onus
is on you to prove it simply saying it
hasn't been proven that there isn't
voter fraud is not
actually sufficient now it gets even
crazier during this interview
here mark meadows claims that despite
numerous reports no voting machines have
been taken offline but if they were
taken offline it's definitely barack
obama's fault
are you saying that sorting machines
have not been taken offline and removed
are you asserting that
that did not happen i'm saying that
shorting
machines between now and the election
will not be taken offline
listen i i had postal undermined the
ones that have been taken offline
no no but listen here's what i'm saying
is
when you look at it the normal process
of doing all of this jake
uh i had the postal system under i had
the only bipartisan bill to actually
deal with the 146 billion dollar loss
that the postal service has been uh will
see over the next 10 years
and so when you're looking at this these
postal machines and the the drawdown
that was a 2006 bill that has been
implemented
that i don't necessarily agree with but
that's not this postmaster general that
that that did that that was the previous
postmaster general
under obama so if you're struggling to
understand that you aren't alone do not
adjust your brain it's actually
incoherent
voting machines haven't been taken
offline but there was a bill under obama
to do it
but it hasn't happened this time but it
did happen but not now so
if it's because of that bill that you
see it then blame obama
what then jake tapper provides evidence
that actually
voting machines are being taken offline
and mark meadows says oh it's all normal
and nothing to be alarmed about but
remember he said minutes earlier
that it wasn't happening at all in terms
of the fact check that you asked me to
look into
yeah one of my great producers did in
terms of the machines
chris bentley president of the national
postal
mail handlers union local 297 which
covers kansas
and part of missouri two good trump
states told cnn
that postal management has already taken
out four machines in kansas city
two machines in springfield missouri and
one machine
in wichita kansas that is earlier this
year
under this new postmaster general no no
no
with all due respect and and if we look
at it i can talk
to kansas i can talk to tucson arizona
you're talking to someone who knows is
when we take out those
processing they're part of a processing
center that come
comes in and as we start to move those
out if they were not part of an already
scheduled
reallocation it's not happening it's not
a new initiative by this postmaster
general and when we look at this
it's all about efficiency but you have a
normal system
of of changing it out and so with with
all due respect of your fact checker
i'll be glad to come in we can spend an
hour talking about this we'll bore
people to death but i can tell you this
the post office has been losing money
for over 10 years
okay so the full explanation is this
isn't happening
if it is it's barack obama's fault not
the current postmaster general
but since it is happening it's actually
not happening now oh well no but it is
but it was the previous postmaster
general whose influence is actually
what's responsible here
and anyway we should treat the post
office like a business instead of the
public service that it is
this is trump's chief of staff this is
not some random congressman
anymore he was some random congressman
now this is donald trump's chief of
staff
we're in real trouble heading into this
election
in a move of total desperation
donald trump has announced that he is
now going to consider pardoning
edward snowden in a completely obvious
gambit
to maybe try to take control of the
election and appeal to
some voters and this is super
interesting partially because donald
trump previously called
for edward snowden to be executed it's
also partially interesting because it's
not clear whether this would actually
help donald trump so let's
take it from the top edward snowden is
the former nsa contractor who's been
living in russia for years to escape
prosecution here in the united states
for leaking classified documents that
exposed
that the nsa and the government uh other
government agencies
were doing this mass bulk surveillance
trump was asked about edward snowden
over the weekend and here's what he had
to say
do you want to give edward snowden a
pardon and bringing back you
you once suggested well i'm going to
look at it i mean i'm not that aware of
the snowden situation but i'm going to
start looking at it
there are many many people it seems to
be a split decision that many people
think that
he should be somehow treated differently
and other people think he did
very bad things and i'm going to take a
very good look at it okay i mean i
i've i've seen people that are very
conservative and very liberal and they
agree on the same issue they
agree both ways uh i'm going to take a
look at that very strongly edward
snowden yeah please
so in trump's mealy-mouthed and confused
way
he's saying yeah he's going to look at
pardoning edward snowden now remember
that donald trump previously said in a
tweet quote
uh snowden is a spy who should be
executed
but if it and he could reveal obama's
records i might become a major fan
trump tweeted about edward snowden
snowden is a traitor and a disgrace make
no mistake he is no hero
in fact he is a coward who should come
back and face justice
trump tweeted snowden is a liar and a
fraud
trump tweeted like it or not edward
snowden is a spy
and should be tried as a spy he has
stolen invaluable information and
damaged us with other nations
trump a second time with the execution
of snowden tweeting
snowden is a spy who has caused great
damage to the us a spy in the old days
when our country was respected and
strong
would be executed trump tweeted
hilariously
message to edward snowden you're banned
from miss universe
unless you want me to take you back home
to face justice so i could go on
trump has 45 tweets about snowden
but the point is trump could not have
been more against
snowden for year after year after year
until now
and to be clear the problem here is not
that trump might
change his mind changing one's mind is
good you learn something new
you re-evaluate your position and your
belief might
be uh modified that's a beautiful thing
we should applaud that rather than
ridicule it the issue here is trump
hasn't learned anything
other than maybe pardoning snowden would
help me in november trump
says in his answer i don't know much
about him
but i'm going to look at a pardon trump
hasn't become informed about snowden
and now thinks maybe we pardon him trump
hasn't suddenly
come out against the surveillance that
snowden exposed
it's merely trump thinking could this
help me in november maybe it could
he barely has an idea who edward snowden
is or what he did
unless putin has been talking to him
about it which would be another
situation altogether so what trump means
by i'm going to take a look at it
is i'm going to think about whether it
might
win me some votes in november that's
absolutely all that this is
hey this is really funny um we have a
voicemail number
2192 david p and a trump
voter was not pleased with one of our
videos from last week that went viral
because i was in a different location
last week and he didn't like the size of
my
microphone take a listen to this
yeah i stumbled across your show uh
you were commenting on donald trump and
um the hannity show
so on so forth i think it's pretty weak
you it just sounds so
weak man put it put a a
picture on the wall from your parents
bedroom there
pretty drab and uh you got a big giant
microphone
what the hell who are you man
you're weak all right keep going keep
going man
we'll just follow the commenting as you
guys lose the election again
all right see you later all right see
you later
um it's funny when people call in they
take the time they've clearly watched
enough to issue
a very specific critique they call in
to tell me how unimportant and and lame
everything i'm doing
is and the criticism is the size of my
microphone
and the fact that i didn't have the
place i was broadcasting from last week
sufficiently decorated to their standard
you know it's a
uh if you want to talk about a weak
criticism that's what it sounds like to
me but i love it i love it we we had
200 new voicemails over the weekend
still going through them and
a lot of action a lot of action make
sure to subscribe to us on youtube we
are
racing to 1 million youtube subscribers
make sure that you get our daily audio
podcast
on any platform which you prefer whether
it's spotify
pandora google play itunes
iheartradio what else is there stitcher
anyway we've also got a great bonus show
coming up for you today and i invite you
to grab a membership at joinpakman.com
to get instant access to today's bonus
[Music]
show
thanks so much for watching today's full
episode of the show just a reminder
today's sponsor is blinkist the app that
lets you
read or listen to an entire nonfiction
book
in just 15 minutes you can try blinkist
for free
and save 25 percent off of a
subscription
when you go to blinkist.com david pakman
i've also included the link right
underneath this video